[Music]
everything that we see and feel around
us is usually termed as matter by now we
even know that matter is classified into
three major states and what are these
three states of matter that's right they
are solid liquid and gas but have you
ever thought about what the matter
around us could be made up of well this
question is not new and has been
addressed a long time ago and many
people have made an attempt to answer it
let us have a look at a few of these
philosophies and theories recorded
evidences suggest that around 500 BC an
Indian philosopher named Maharaja Carnot
hypothesized a concept his curiosity
about components of matter made him put
forth an idea he suggested that when we
divide matter into tiny apart Achatz
ultimately we reach a stage when the
matter cannot be divided further these
particles which cannot be divided
further make up the matter the matter
was called padartha in the Indian
language and he named the particles as
per Manu on similar lines another Indian
philosopher named Bakura katayama made
slight modification in maharaja
connard's work and elaborated saying
that such indivisible particles come in
different combinations to make up
different kinds of matter around the
same era two Greek philosophers also
suggested the same concept the two
personalities were Democritus and
Lucifer's they also postulated that if
we divide matter continuously then we
reach a stage where it cannot be divided
further these indivisible particles does
make up the complete matter
Democritus named these particles as
atomists meaning indivisible now you may
say that this concept is known to us yes
I agree but we are familiar with this
concept now in the era when people were
not really aware of anything in science
such concepts proved useful in laying
the foundations for modern invention
around the end of the 18th century a few
scientists could prove these suggestions
correct they not only discovered
researched about atoms but also threw
light on the basic difference between
elements and compounds yes studying this
difference based away from many
scientists to understand how several
combinations can lead to the formation
of different substances but now when I
say combinations it means we will have
chemical reactions right that's correct
and chemical reactions are governed by a
few important laws this fact was
understood and accepted widely when
foundations of chemical sciences were
led by the French nobleman and chemist
Antoine Lavoisier the two most important
laws of chemical combination were
established by then they were popularly
known as the law of conservation of mass
and the law of constant proportions let
us take a look at both these laws in the
upcoming videos
[Music]